je t'ai laissé dix ans pour vivre ta vie
rémi reiss
et qu'est-ce que tu en as fait
tu es resté dans le nombre
je t'ai entraîner
pour que les hommes les plus dangereux
au monde
ne puisse pas te tuer
[Musique]
l'heure est venue pour toi de prendre
place
chaque mois
jeunes torse centré par
tu ne peux pas échapper
à celui que tu m'aimes
qui êtes vous
[Musique]
ah bon
franck est commis
on fait une bonne équipe
[Musique]
aucun texte d'accord
france 3
[Musique]
le maire
pourquoi pas
le service
ce 6e place
[Musique]
également transmis
les faux
à
[Musique]
le sommet
obama
[Musique]
matin la police a effectué des
perquisitions dans la somptueuse
propriété de l'homme d'affaires gilles
fontaine la villa caprices dans quelles
conditions ce domaine at il été acquis
en 2017
mais il s'appelle l'avocat l autre la
ferme où je me dépasse jamais chez un
client pour un premier entretien je me
déplaçais méchas fillon pour un premier
entretien damman dire une poule de luxe
non excusez moi mais c'est seulement
monsieur chanter
mais ducharme il le sait il en joue
je peux encore dit oui bien sûr qu'a dit
oui
regardez moi cette merveille germain
[Musique]
même s'il m'a frappé
désolé de vous connaître
entraînez garde à vous et sait jamais
[Musique]
pour partir du principe que le juge a
toujours un coup d'avancé sur vous
nous sommes ici pour examiner les
conditions dans lesquelles vous avez
acquis une propriété
mais très précieux à vous savez
très précieux
vous allez être mis en examen tough
trade
nous confortons de kampala ah mais c'est
beaucoup moins cher
toujours pensé que cette saison serait à
moins de jeu
[Musique]
votre 10 en puissance est un leurre on
vous paye pas on vous achète
[Musique]
que vous m'avez tellement manqué les
vagues chéri
cette fille c'est mon héroïne
de leur compte en 10 dont je vais aller
surfer ton reflet dans l'océan
et vous
[Musique]
je veux toujours sentir ton contact je
serai toujours là pour toi quoi qu'il
arrive et tu seras là pour moi pendant
combien de temps jusqu'à ce que tu
réussisses sur fait impropre vague
wii nadeau
reflet dans l'océan
j'étais promis que je serai toujours là
si tu as besoin de moi c'est à chaque
fois que je chante
tu apparais dans l'eau à chaque fois que
je chante cette chanson qui
plus jamais je pourrais tenir la main
dans là c'est tout embrasser ça me fait
mal de te le dire n'est minato est mort
[Musique]
oh la vache
et
danseur justin qui tue c'était mon mail
y aura mieux maternelle c'est lui mais
que plus gentil que je cotise est invité
par la mariée ou le mile a en fait eu
des puces les mariés demain je vais y
aller et lui demander devant tous les
invités s'il est vraiment sûr depuis
le jour de son mariage des sûr de ton
coup c'est peut-être un peu trop tard
je viens de me marier
c'est différent dans un autre univers il
en existe des millions
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai comme une impression j'ai vécu
déjà rêver je suis un mariage et je suis
sûr que j'ai déjà vu ici je représente
en tonnes en bonnet mis d'accord
renseigne-toi moi aussi j'ai fait un
très bon ami l'a fait quoi tu veux
construire d'ici justement non il faut
que je reste je dois faire un truc hyper
important
salut je croyais que tu étais au mariage
pas aujourd'hui oui je passe une bonne
journée avec moi même si je m'endors
maintenant tu auras oublier cette
journée et la journée d'avant
tu te fait penser à un truc vraiment
merdique non c'est
j'ai fait l'amour avec mon coloc que je
n'ai pas fait qu'une seule fois mais
plein plein de fois les toits est ce que
tu laisses je sais pas mais on rit
beaucoup je te demande de quitter ce
mariage est un peu le revers sur
l'enfant
70 la vérité si l'espèce marié c'est
leur décision
sa vitesse qui donne pas voir chez toi
dis moi ce que je suis censé faire rien
à part sourire
[Musique]
azad bieber sans magath de l'ostéopathie
photo atta mills note à migros baissent
man s meira
penser
à celle
qui saute
[Musique]
peut-être ça et me khan pacha seat
prochain
[Musique]
riedisheim convaincu économique
karachi sud
[Musique]
madame
ciao
pour allécher
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
shimizu à
masina ramamurthy nomades
[Musique]